Hey, Thoughty2 here.
If you’ve ever felt swamped by the chaos of
it all and crave some time alone in nature,
why not venture to Gruinard Island? This
remote lump of land off the northwest coast
of Scotland is utterly uninhabited and devoid
of irritating modern conveniences like wifi,
running water or reliable shelter. Encircled
by the frosty waters of the North Atlantic,
you could even satisfy your
penchant for cold water swimming.
But along with your speedos you might want to pack
your hazmat suit. And instead of sun cream - it’s
Scotland - it’s probably a good idea to top
up your vaccinations - specifically the kind
that protects you from deadly bacterial
infections. Oh, and don’t be alarmed if
locals refer to your new holiday spot as ‘the
Island of Death’ - according to the British
Ministry of Defence, it’s *perfectly*
safe to visit. Well, it is now anyway...
Because, for a solid 50 years, beginning in
the early 1940s, this two-square-kilometre
island in the arse end of nowhere was one of
the most perilous places on earth thanks to
one of the most bizarre covert operations of
the Second World War: Operation Vegetarian.
Despite the name, it wasn’t an assault on
humanity’s herbivores. Quite the contrary - it
was a crazy campaign against carnivores:
specifically the German ones. For that reason,
it was arguably one of the most misnamed
military campaigns of the 20th century,
right up there with Operation Toenails, the
invasion of New Georgia by Allied troops,
Operations Red Bean and Frequent Wind, which
must have been unpleasant for everyone involved,
and Operations Beaver Cage and Viking Snatch,
the less said about those, the better.
Operation Vegetarian was a proposed
bio-warfare campaign during World
War II that aimed to sabotage the
German food supply by contaminating
cattle with anthrax - the horrific bacterial
infection, not the American thrash metal band
(though I’m just cattle wouldn’t
like that very much either).
The plan was the brain fart, I mean,
brainchild, of British scientist Paul
Fildes, a distinguished biology boffin
who, three years into World War II,
was tasked with concocting a biological
weapon that could turn the tide on Hitler.
His answer was simple: drop millions of
anthrax-laced linseed cakes across Germany during
the summer when the nation’s cattle would be out
grazing. If everything went to plan, the cattle
would consume the cakes and become infected,
subsequently infecting the people who ate *them*.
If it turned out the cattle
didn’t like the taste of anthrax,
the cakes would simply dissolve the next
time it rained, poisoning the grass,
which the cows would eventually eat anyway. Either
way, things would end badly for the bovines.
The bacteria that causes anthrax, Bacillus
anthracis, can be inhaled, ingested or absorbed
through direct contact with the skin, but the
side effects are ultimately the same: sepsis,
multiple organ failure, and swelling of the fluid
and membranes around the brain and spinal cord,
resulting in extensive internal
bleeding, and, eventually, death.
Cutaneous anthrax - the one you get through
your skin - is the most common form,
and inhalation anthrax is the deadliest,
but gastrointestinal anthrax - the one
the British planned to spread through Operation
Vegetarian - isn’t far behind. Left untreated,
over half of gastrointestinal anthrax
patients perish, and even if treated
with the right antibiotics, which weren’t around
in 1942 anyway, 40% of patients don’t make it.
Anthrax is not man-made. Bacillus anthracis
is found naturally all over the world,
mainly in soil. It mostly infects farmed and
wild animals, who occasionally transmit it
to humans. Some scholars think it was the
real cause of the 5th plague in the Bible,
which describes a sickness that afflicts
livestock. Today, we still witness roughly
2,000 cases annually. Operation Vegetarian
would have dwarfed those numbers.
The plan was to contaminate Germany’s
beef cattle, possibly infecting humans who
feasted on the meat, but at the very least
killing all the cows, creating a colossal
food shortage that would force the Nazis to
reroute resources and attention away from
beating the crap out of half of Europe. But
this logic was flawed from the outset. When
Paul Fildes started his research, Hitler
and his forces were at the peak of their
European expansion, granting them access to
food supplies far beyond Germany’s borders.
Killing a lot of local cows would have been
horrible, but it wouldn’t have starved the nation.
So, not a particularly pragmatic strategy, but
that was far from the worst of it. Operation
Vegetarian, despite its tree-hugging name, was
an ethical catastrophe. Had it been carried out
it would have been impossible to control
the spread of anthrax, which would have
infected not only the targeted cattle, but also
other animals, humans and even the land itself,
potentially killing millions and rendering
all of Germany uninhabitable for generations.
In fairness, the British didn’t know all of this
at the time. To discover anthrax’s full lethality,
they would first need to do the
sciency bit and test the stuff,
and for that they would need
a remote, unoccupied area far
away from people - especially people
who were likely to ask inconvenient
questions. Which brings us back to Gruinard
Island, your next dream holiday destination.
In 1942, scientists from Porton Down, the
government’s biochemical research lab in southern
England, descended on Gruinard Island, taking
60 sheep along for company. In the first test,
a modified plane dropped an anthrax bomb
on the island, killing all 60 sheepies,
but also some animals on the mainland
nearby. Later tests involving anthrax
cake bombs caused more unplanned spread of
the disease when a contaminated sheep carcass
washed up on a shore across the bay, sparking
an outbreak of anthrax in local animals and
livestock. The government told farmers a
passing Greek ship was to blame and hushed
everything up through the tactical use of some
very generous bribes - I mean compensation.
Despite the collateral damage, anthrax bombs were
clearly a very deadly success. Gruinard Island
was transformed into a forbidding hellscape,
threatening death upon any setting foot on its
shores. So, what did the British military
do to remedy this environmental disaster?
Carry out a thorough decontamination
program, restoring the once pristine island?
Nah. They put up a big ‘no
entry’ sign, and buggered off.
Now, if you’re thinking, ‘Wow, those anthrax
experiments sound terrifying - thank God the
Brits abandoned the project and made themselves a
cup of tea instead’, you would be only partially
correct - there was almost certainly tea involved,
but the devastating tests on Gruinard Island
didn’t slow Operation Vegetarian down one
bit. Quite the opposite. Inspired by their
newfound ability to kill lots of living things
within a few days, the British military entered
full-scale production, and by 1943 they’d
stockpiled 5 million anthrax cakes ready
for distribution across Germany. As the summer
of 1944 approached, Operation Vegetarian was
officially ready to bear fruit. Or vegetables.
Actually, cake… Whatever. It was ready.
But when the time came to execute the anthrax
apocalypse, the need for decimating an entire
country with a murderous pathogen had disappeared.
With the successful invasion of Normandy behind
them, the Allies were steadily moving
across Europe, with the Nazis on the
retreat. Operation Vegetarian was abandoned, and
the 5 million anthrax cakes were incinerated,
along with all the taxpayers’ money that had
gone into making them. I think I speak for
everyone and their cows when I say, thank
God. Not only would it have been an act
of tremendous cruelty that would forever have
shifted the lines of what’s permissible in war,
the Brits still didn’t know the full
potential of what they were dealing with.
Yes, they had proved anthrax could be a lethal
weapon, but they had no idea how long its effects
would last. That they discovered when they
went back to Gruinard Island after the war.
Scientists assumed the anthrax contamination
would neutralise itself after a few years, but
the spores proved to be incredibly resilient, and
decontamination efforts failed miserably. Gruinard
remained a death trap for decades, a fact that
became public knowledge when a Ministry of Defence
video was declassified in 1980. The footage
showed the experiments that had been performed
almost 40 years before and resulted in a public
outcry. Just kidding, no one really gave a shit.
Well, *almost* no-one. A small band
of revolutionaries calling themselves,
rather ominously, the Dark Harvest Commando of the
Scottish Citizen Army… they gave lots of shits.
These rebels first announced themselves to the
world in 1981 when a mysterious note was pinned to
the front door of St. Andrew’s House, home of the
Scottish Government in Edinburgh. They claimed to
have assembled a crack team of hard bastards
that included at least two microbiologists,
and that they’d visited Gruinard island to collect
over 100 kilograms of poisoned soil. This soil,
they threatened, would be left
in strategic locations around
the country until the government
paid attention. Shortly afterwards,
a package of anthrax soil was discovered
at Porton Down, the facility where
Operation Vegetarian was developed. The Dark
Harvest Commandos appeared to mean business.
Clearly unsettled, the British
government sprang into action…
5 years later. In 1986 the worst of the
topsoil was removed, and everything left
behind was sprayed with a mixture of sea
water and formaldehyde. In April 1990,
the quarantine was lifted, and Gruinard Island
was officially declared safe-ish to visit.
In 1972 the Biological Weapons Convention was
created, banning countries from developing,
producing, stockpiling or using biological
weapons. 185 countries signed up, effectively
making it illegal for governments and militaries
to muck about with substances like anthrax.
Hopefully, thanks to monstrous
mistakes like Operation Vegetarian,
we’re becoming a little smarter about
the downsides of mass destruction,
and can look forward to a more peaceful
world for all of mankind…… and cows.
Thanks for watching.